and welcome to Hannity all right tonight
chaos in New York criminals now are
roaming the streets we have disturbing
new video that shows a violent felon
brutally assaulting this woman we showed
you earlier in the week a random attack
on a subway platform near the airport
the attacker previously beat his own
grandmother to death was out on parole
for a variety of other crimes that woman
the victim I can't believe after that
beating she was able to get up now she
may permanently lose vision in her right
eye she will join us to tell us about
this harrowing moment Straight Ahead
also later get ready buckle up ESPN host
our buddy Stephen A Smith will join us
we'll get his take on the gruesome
injury from last night's Thursday night
football game we'll get to that but we
begin tonight in the Washington swamp
now led by some of the dumbest most
incompetent people on the face of the
Earth our economies in a shambles
because of their Reckless spending gas
prices they're going up through the roof
again because of their war on American
Energy average price per gallon in LA
today six dollars and 26 Cents Statewide
in California six dollars eighteen cents
you live in Oregon 5.29 Washington State
five dollars and Seventeen cents and
it's only going higher now our kids have
fallen behind in school because of their
unscientific covert restrictions illegal
immigration opioid fentanyl deaths are
at an all-time high because of their
Reckless open border policy we have
Europe at War because of their weakness
and of course in Afghanistan and now we
have Vladimir Putin threatening to use
tactical nuclear weapons and today
pretty much declaring that one-third of
Ukraine is now his and in the wake of
Hurricane Ian Florida's Gulf Coast is
now lucky to have strong state and local
leadership because obviously the
president of the United States is not
mentally capable of coordinating
anything take a look
the FEMA administrator who's become the
MVP here these days I spent a lot of
time in this room uh griswell FEMA and
an entire Workforce the people directly
impacted by Hurricane Ian I'm going to
use this
it made landfall yesterday but we're
here to talk about America okay thank
you thank you Mr President
I don't think he knows the name of his
home FEMA director and it gets worse
earlier this week this was maybe the
lowest of all lows when he attempted to
introduce a congresswoman that he was
supposed to be honoring who tragically
passed away in an accident in August and
instead of honoring that Legacy
um he asked her uh where she is take a
look
and I want to thank all of you here
Frank including bipartisan elected
officials like representative Governor
Senator Braun Senator Booker
representative Jackie are you here
where's Jackie I didn't think she was
going to be here to help make this a
reality
I want to thank all of you for being
here and Booker and uh where's Jackie
where's Jackie okay this guy's not
mentally competent for any job much less
the hardest job in the world that being
president but frankly his vice president
she's not much better during kamala's
trip to Asia yeah she made a complete
fool out of herself and frankly did not
make our country look particularly good
take a look
and it's so close it's it's 50 meters
away that's that's right that's it so
the United States
shares a very important relationship
which is an alliance with the Republic
of North Korea
and it is an alliance that is strong and
enduring
and today there were several
demonstrations of just that point
a very important great alliance with
North Korea wow I can't believe it's so
close 50 meters ma'am great job Kamala
as usual now the next in line to be your
president would be 82 year old Nancy
Pelosi and while Nancy constantly finds
a way to outperform the stock market
well her job performance as Speaker yeah
that's always lacking here's her take on
what she's calling hurricane
Iran take a look
almost 19 billion Australia's disaster
really fun some of it needed right away
for for Iran uh iron but Ian but it's
more will be needed
hurricane Iran in the same speech she
touted the merits of immigrants staying
in Southern States because she needs
them she wants them to pick uh our fruit
and vegetables take a look
you see even in Florida some of the
farmers and The Growers saying why are
you shipping these
immigrants up north we need them to pick
the crops down here why send them to
Martha's Vineyard why send them to D.C
or New York or her State the sanctuary
State of California what a truly stupid
thing to say and insulting frankly to
all the legal immigrant working uh
people that come into this country obey
all laws respect our borders in
sovereignty and work in a variety of
professions all across the country now
after decades in politics Pelosi Biden
Harris they've all lost touch with
reality they don't understand the
ramifications of their god-awful
policies they don't have any empathy for
you the American people they are totally
insulated from any and all socioeconomic
hardship and they lack all the moral
courage to ever admit failure and
reverse core course in fact Joe Biden's
biggest concern at the moment is that
Italy is soon going to have a
conservative prime minister that
believes that you ought to be able to
call yourself an Italian a Christian a
mother and a woman at a closed-door
fundraiser Biden said that she is the
quote the reason why I'm so concerned
that democracy is at stake the people in
Italy voted are in Joe and while the
White House is moaning and groaning
about a new European leader who isn't a
woke European socialist Americans here
at home have bigger fish to fry in just
two years this inept Administration and
of course their climate cult they have
nearly destroyed the American dream for
all of us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else